la part des miens a amené son lot de
difficultés pour les personnes sans
doute une errance entre autres à
montréal bien la ville a décidé d'ouvrir
trois sites d'hébergement d'urgence qui
seront ouverts jusqu'au printemps
par ailleurs des chercheurs de
l'université mcgill sont intéressés aux
façons les plus efficaces et les plus
économiques pour combattre l'itinérance
j'en discute avec mon invité le docteur
éric latimer il est auteur principal de
cette étude bonjour docteur latimer jeu
alors ces refus refuge d'urgence
l'annoncé par la ville de montréal
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est une bonne
façon d'investir pour vaincre
l'itinérant justement je crois que ces
refuges en fait ne sont pas destinés à
vaincre l'itinérance en tant que tel
mais simplement à permettre aux
personnes en situation d'itinérance
actuellement d'avoir un lieu où aller et
d'assurer aussi plus de distanciation
physique qu'il n'en existait auparavant
oui mais je on voit dedans l'autre part
de l' annonce faite par la mairesse de
de fournir des suppléments au loyer et
du soutien pour 200 personnes qui
pourront aller vers des logements
permanents
là on voit le gens d'après ch en fait
dont il est question dans notre étude et
qui est louis peut mener main
directement à une réduction dans
l'itinérance
parce que votre étude justement on y
conclut qu'on réussira à faire des
économies importantes d'ailleurs sont
privilégiés justement le modèle logement
d'abord qu'est ce que c'est exactement
ce modèle le modèle logement d'abord
existe depuis plusieurs années même
existe à montréal depuis environ 5-6 ans
sans compter les études antérieures ont
commencé en 2009 c'est connu sous le
vocable stabilité résidentielle avec
accompagnement en bref il s'agit de
directement proposé à une personne en
situation d'itinérance un choix de deux
logements autonomes
ray aucun l'on va sortir un supplément
au loyer calculé pour faire en sorte que
la personne ne va payer que 25 à 30% de
ses revenus
on le loue à vie l'autre contribution
dans le cas présent vient soit de
l'office l'habitation de montréal soit
du gouvernement fédéral par le biais
d'un du programme d'arracher soit
actuellement
et une fois que la personne est logé
parce qu'il faut reconnaître que ce sont
des personnes qui ont beaucoup de
difficultés il faut leur donner un
soutien pour leur permettent de se
stabiliser de progresser dans leur vie
et dans votre étude vous aborder surtout
la question des personnes qui ont des
problèmes plus graves de santé mentale
oui dans l'étude qui avaient été menées
le projet chez soi en 2009 à 2013
les participants étaient répartis selon
leur niveau de besoin en un groupe a
besoin élevé et un groupe a besoin
modéré l'intervention pour les personnes
à besoins il veut plus intensive et
coûtait en moyenne à travers les sites
canadiens
vingt mille dollars par personne par
année tandis que celles pour les
personnes à besoins modéré coûté 14 8
500 dollars par personne par année
est ce que nous avons trouvé donc c'est
que dans l'un et l'autre des
interventions une partie importante du
coût de l'intervention était récupéré
par des économies au chapitre des
refuges d'urgence logements de
transition services ambulatoires
traitement pour alcoolisme toxicomanie
donc les équipes d'intervention se
substituait et les appartements se
substituer à ces services là mais ce que
nous avons trouvé le point fondamental
de l'étude ici c'est que les
interventions pour les personnes à
besoins élevés quoique plus coûteuse au
départ j'ai dit vingt mille comparer à
15 9 500 permet une plus grande
récupération de coûts que l'autre donc
ça c'est plus rapide
au final c'est plus rentable ça revient
on a estimé carl de dollars par jour de
logement stable comparé à 56 pour les
personnes aient besoin modéré le temps
file monsieur latimer mais j'aimerais
juste savoir rapidement on sait que
c'est difficile le logement à montréal
entre hommes et dans d'autres villes
aussi si louable de vouloir loger ces
gens là mais est ce que c'est possible
en quelques secondes
oui c'est possible
c'est certain que le marché locatif
actuel pose un défi et les gouvernements
auraient besoin d'investir pour
augmenter l'offre de logements
abordables à montréal c'est certain
merci beaucoup monsieur le maire merci
beaucoup au revoir